I flew into San Francisco on Friday
night and the smoke hanging over that
city was amazing
turning now to domestic politics
President Trump is working to reset his
relationship with Senate Republicans the
president scheduled to discuss his
legislative agenda today with Senate
Majority Leader Mitch McConnell at the
White House the meeting comes after the
president former chief strategist this
weekend back McConnell and the
Republican establishment Johnny Anna
Goldman is at the White House Julianna
good morning good morning well that's
right president's former advisor Steve
Bannon declared war on the Republican
establishment and Mitch McConnell
further complicating the president's
efforts to work with McConnell and
congressional Republicans on tax reform
Senator Rand Paul said he narrowly lost
to the president during their golf
outing Sunday but he hopes mr. Trump can
score a big win on tax reform
the president took South Carolina
Republican Lindsey Graham golfing
Saturday and will lunch with Senate
Majority Leader Mitch McConnell today
all outreach to make sure votes on the
budget this week and later tax reform
are successful yeah Mitch the donors the
donors are not happy they've all left
you former chief White House strategist
Steve Bannon tauren - McConnell at the
conservative values voter summit this
weekend Benin believes McConnell is
responsible for president Trump's
legislative failures and threatened to
support primary opponents of three
sitting Republicans if they don't vote
to oust McConnell as leader nobody can
run it hot on this one these folks are
coming for you but within hours of
bannon's remarks mr. Trump called
McConnell to discuss their legislative
priorities and to invite him to today's
lunch according to a source familiar
with the call Benin can't beat us if
we're successful
senator Graham brushed off bannon's
criticisms and said leader McConnell is
not the problem our problem is that we
promise to repeal and replace Obamacare
and we failed we promise to cut taxes
and we've yet to do it if we're
successful Mitch McConnell's fine if
we're not we're all in trouble
over the weekend Bannon pointed to his
track record and noted his victory last
month in Alabama where his candidate
conservative Roy Moore the incumbent
senator Luther Strange who was backed by
McConnell and the president Norah all
right we'll be watching Juliana thank
you